[Music]  okay so first off i just want to say  i get it  you get what  high school kamala kamala another  adventure shirt cute  she thinks i'm some kind of weirdo you  were a weirdo boys excuse me yeah  you're kind of on my shirt sorry  but you're staring at the window in your  little fantasy land  kamala hey already really come on like  do i have to figure out my whole future  before  launchers maybe they're right  i spend too much time  and fantasyland  that is not to you  it's not really the brown girls from  jersey city  you save the world  that's a fantasy too  did something happen to you no why did  you hear something come on  what does it feel like  cosmic  i always thought i wanted this kind of  life  [Music]  but i never imagined any of this  do you know what you are  i'm a superhero  [Music]  you